and EG is breaking news my former  dancing partner is bringing the sexy  back netted uh slipping scope she's back  ladies and gentlemen Dancing with the  Stars this is exciting very exciting but  I can't believe it I never thought that  would be back we still got it and it  originally left in 2010 to raise a  family and she thinks dancing will  always be home for the house they had  such a great and long career in this and  Derek won like million times I think  it's time for them to move on and do  they own the thing I'm sure they will be  bad I've been talking to her producers  for a couple of seasons and it wasn't  right before I had a baby I had my own  tour so this season I just felt like  having a mummy for two years and coming  back would be such a challenge  you